hey hello everybody and welcome to
episode 10 of my payto playay flipping
Series where we're going to go from Z to
100 Mil using the grand exchange only so
this week our uh progress has been a
little bit stunted by the fact that I've
been gone for so long I actually had my
membership expire while I was gone I had
like seven days left on it when I left
came back and was totally expired um so
unfortunately we didn't make the huge
progress that we were hoping to make but
um next episode I promise we're
definitely getting there and we got some
changes to uh the res solution
everything will be in the next episode
um so without further Ado we're starting
at about
10.9 mil and yeah let's get into the
video and see where we can get from
here okay so to start off we're going to
do a crystal key flip actually uh so to
do this you have to buy pretty much four
items you have to well no sorry you have
to buy and sell uh the tooth half of the
key you have to buy and sell the loop
half of the key to get the margins as
well as buy the full Crystal Key at
least buy it uh so what you're doing is
you're taking the low price for the
tooth half of the key and the loop half
of the key um and then you're going to
subtract that off the high price of the
Crystal Key um so you're going to see
what the margin is there generally a
good margin for this is about 1,000 um
per key that you make um so we're going
to think we're going to get two or 300
here this doesn't always work but when
it does it's quite good money I mean you
can get a couple Mill hour doing this
assuming you already have the the
components for
it um but yeah in this case I think we
have a the 1K margin on it and uh we'll
go ahead and buy 300 of the or sorry 250
of the tooth halfs 250 of the loop halfs
then we'll just combine them and then
we'll resell
them okay so we bought all the keys uh
we didn't unfortunately get them
perfectly all for the same price but we
got 27 of the keys for about 8,900 and
we got 40 something of the keys for a
little bit less um but anyway we should
still be making some profit here
hopefully um all we're going to do is
combine the keys I'll just show the clip
kind of sped up in the background
quickly it's pretty easy all you do is
withdraw 14 of each key the easiest way
is if you drag one of the halfes down to
the bottom right corner and start spam
clicking there um you can get an
inventory done in like probably 20
seconds or something so it's pretty
quick and yeah we'll do all these and
then we'll just uh sell them so after
all that uh we actually ended up losing
money uh the crystal Keys crashed down a
bit and I think the margin wasn't as big
as I thought to begin with um just to
give you some numbers I mean we sold
them all for 9.6 mil um but we bought
them all for like 9.7 mil or something
unfortunately uh we ended up losing
about 80k after calculations again this
does happen sometimes we're not going to
give up I think we're going to try it
again um but just to show this is
doesn't always
work okay so we're going to try the
crystal Keys again uh this time we
actually have a much bigger margin you
can see there 1459 is what we got this
time that's actually after looking back
in the last clip that's more in double
what it was last time so I think this
time we should be more safe buying these
I really should have looked at the
charts to see if um the items were their
average price or not um but whatever
we're going to go ahead and probably buy
another couple hundred of these each uh
250 Keys each and um I think we might
have enough money to get one more item
after this but just to do a quick
calculation theoretically if we get the
margin on it which is500 we should get
about 375k from this and the buying
limit for these things are very high so
theoretically if you had a bunch of
money you would would be able to get
over like 2 3 mil an hour sometimes
doing this I saw some guy said he made
21 mil I don't know but anyway we will
come back when the keys have sold so the
keys have sold and uh this time we did
much better we kept pretty close to the
original margin we got about 1250 on
each one and times 250 Keys gives us
about 315k which is pretty good for how
easy it was and uh the energy potions we
did as well uh we didn't record it in
the future we're just going to kind of
show you the end flip for these these
items we've done a bunch um but yeah the
energy potions we got 55 GP on each
times 2,000 gives us about 109k which is
awesome that's pretty nice flip for only
two items again the crystal keys are
nice because they have a very high
buying limit I think it's like 10,000 or
something I don't know uh but you're not
likely to hit the cap unless you have a
ton of money which is nice uh so yeah we
will maybe do this one more time this
episode but let's go have a look for
some more items so actually I think
we're going to do the crystal Keys again
now they still have about a 1K margin on
them about um so we're going to go ahead
and I think we can
afford 200 300 of them I guess we'll do
280 just to check the margin it looks
like it's 1,52 which is pretty good and
uh yeah we'll come back when these have
sold might grab another potion along the
way but uh we'll just come back after uh
the keys
sold okay we're back and um we didn't
unfortunately buy all of the loop or
sorry the tooth half of the keys uh for
whatever reason they stopped buying so I
think what we're going to do is uh we're
going to combine all the keys we can and
then sell back the tooth half of a key
as just a regular flip uh also on the
side note we did get some magic potions
uh which we only got about 20 GP margin
on given us about 39K so nothing special
there but uh we did get some money from
that and yes so we'll go combine the
keys we'll settle them back and um we'll
try to calculate how much we made off
this flip cuz it'll be a little
confusing okay so we're back and we have
sold everything uh so we're going to
start with uh the loop half of the keys
cuz that was just a normal flip we ended
up getting a 248 GP margin on them uh
which is not great but we got 174 of
them giving us
43k um that's what we just took there
and the Crystal keys after calculating
everything out we got about 154k on
those uh given us just less than a 1K
margin on each key uh so it's not not
too bad um it's a little messy when this
happens it's kind of nice when you just
py all the keys and sell them but uh
either way we're doing pretty good and
uh we'll get a couple more flips
going okay so first up we're going to do
the adamant Dart tips or sorry just Adam
darts has a 4gp margin on it and I think
you can get 11,000 of these every hour
probably 10K or 11k or something uh but
yeah seems pretty decent we get a pretty
easy 40 50k from these okay so next up
we're going to do the dragon axe which
actually has about 4.5k margin on each
one uh which is pretty good I think the
B buying limit is about 40 for those uh
so I mean theoretically if we do hit the
buying limit we could get couple hundred
K pretty easy um but we'll go ahead and
buy I think we'll get yeah we can get 40
actually yeah we'll do 40 and next up I
think we're going to do the death Rune
um a 6gp margin on death Rune is pretty
massive for really how many you Trad
every day I mean there's 100 Millions
probably and uh yeah there's a 10K limit
so that's pretty easy 60k it's a quick
flip but it's pretty effective still and
last up I think we're going to do the
super energy potion um we're just
keeping it in there just for a bit of
variety but um yeah it has about a 167
GP margin on it I think and we can
afford about um 800 of them so we'll go
ahead and do that and we'll come back
when the rest of our items have sold so
everything has sold and we did pretty
good on this flip um we'll start with
the Adam and dart tips uh we only got
one GP on them in the end of the day
which is great so just 11k from the dart
tip
uh the dragon axe we actually still got
a really nice margin on that we got
about 6,800 on each one and we got 26
Dragon axes giving this
176k uh the death runes we still got a
six GP margin on they actually instantly
Spot while I was finishing it up um and
got 10K of those giv us 60k from that
and the super energy potions we got
about 134 GP margin on each one and 800
of those giving us
107k uh all in all I think we got about
350k from this flip uh which pretty good
I might do a couple of these items again
the dragon ax has worked really well so
I might do that in the future um but
yeah we'll do a couple more flips so to
start off I think we're actually going
to do the dragon axes again they worked
quite well last time they have a three
4K margin on them still which is good
they're traded pretty frequently um and
you do hit that 40 40 limit pretty quick
uh but there's no that's not a reason
not to do it uh so we'll go ahead and
buy another 40 Dragon axes and we'll get
them for about 109 I think so next up
we're probably going to do this Archer
Helm it has a 4K margin actually a
little bit more than that and I have to
assume people still use this helmet uh
so we'll go ahead and buy maybe probably
30 or 40 of these again I don't know
what the buying limit is um probably not
going to do 100 actually we'll do 50 um
but yeah I I would say it's probably
close to 50 and we'll see how many of
these we can get so we've uh sold all
the dragon axes and the Archer Helms uh
we did try to get another flip in there
for potions but that did not happen
unfortunately um but we did pretty good
on the dragon axes we got a about 2.9k
on each one and 39 of those gives us
about 112k the Archer Helms actually did
pretty well as well as well uh we got
about 4900 on the Archer Helms and we
got 19 of those giving us about 93k
that's what 200k flip in total which is
pretty decent um so now basically from
this time we're on day seven for the
next seven days I was gone so we're just
going to quickly hop forward in time to
uh when I get back and uh then we'll
just renew our membership and then I
think we're going to call that the end
of the
episode okay we are back and our
membership is expired uh so we'll go
ahead and buy a new Bond um but while
I'm doing that I'll just calculate how
much we made this episode we would have
made a lot more had not been gone for a
week uh but nothing to do about that so
we will go ahead and calculate so we
started at about 10. 9 mil approximately
and uh we ended at 12 mil actually so
pretty decent we got over 1.1 mil or
something something along those lines so
pretty decent we'll go ahead and buy a
bond here bring this down to about 9.1
mil so we didn't really make much
progress in this membership period but
um next time I'm going to definitely put
more effort into making sure we get some
progress going yeah thanks for watching
guys I will see you guys in episode 11
we'll have some changes to the
resolution then we got some other
changes in the works uh but yeah thanks
for watching guys again if you enjoyed
hit that subscribe button and I will see
you guys next
[Music]
time